[Music]
this week we've got tech combat
second-story crash and an
attention-seeking Rob err yeah
Robert wow that's fun Lee if you name a
kid Robert he's gonna be a robber
real bad jo ho but night my name is
Joseph nothing rhymes with Joseph and no
is a wholesale process
all right Brad first story you guys
remember Circuit City commercial where
the [ __ ] plug goes in the ground like
that that's my favorite bunch of it
these people would work there and they
would steal their [ __ ] and hook people
up with car radio [ __ ] Vietnamese people
I remember good guys too Oh a lot of
Mexican people would work there and then
they would have their Mexican friends
would [ __ ] good guys was Mexicans yeah
so the only people that survived was
fries and Best Buy yeah and I hate Best
Buy fries used to be called something
else I forgot what it was called like
Universal world I really kind of hate
all of them fries is always dimly lit
you can see should have this weird like
alien themed thing and I'm like all the
more different themes so some of their
cowboy
depends on a location yeah the one that
burping is a giant bug beam there's like
a giant ant in the middle of it why did
the fog like this person that super
[ __ ] creative was like [ __ ] what do I
do with my creativity but none of them
have enough lights though incredible
universe
that's what used to be called scientists
anything oh yeah
when I first went there for incredible
universe I thought it was gonna be like
a playpen thing and it was just so my
dad could buy a computer I was held
behind that because there was like a
huge like no Saturn in the middle all
this like stars the [ __ ]
I walk in as a warehouse of like [ __ ]
this I think you'd be the only child I
would ever abuse really you wouldn't
abuse me at all I was an amazing child
mm-hmm
yeah well Circuit City has announced
that they
be making a comeback why they're gonna
fail again Amazon [ __ ] killing it
right now they're gonna be online huh
yeah exactly they're gonna be online
like Tiger Direct well but so initially
they're gonna start their comeback with
only being in e-commerce websites so
only doing it online but then slowly
they want to have modest locations I
thought Tiger Direct was the one that
bought circuits they closed their last
door back in 2009 and then yeah it was
bought it was sold and bought by and
many different companies but now the
people who have gotten it they are the
ones that are trying to your business
pulls down into a 2009 but then like you
buy it in 2018 or 2017 and then you go
you know what I think pagers are gonna
come back no no I'm saying like it's
like buying a pager company right
because you know Amazon just owns
everything yeah what exactly are you
buying when the business dies I just buy
the name like what assets if I'll have
the last brick-and-mortar shuts down and
I'm pretty sure no one knows that yeah
I'm just wondering like my first thought
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you buying
that you're bringing back but when you
when you buy businesses though you're
not you're not just buying product
you're buying all the connections all
their sales reps everything so those
fools like [ __ ] Phil Phil Rodriguez
is just sitting there waiting for a job
so it's a it's an already functioning
business so let's say barbell you want
to sell barbell right they're not buying
your brand really just that they're
buying they're buying them they're
trying to buy your team how you made
stuff how you did everything so when
they walk in it's a fully functioning
business and all they have to do is plug
in person how did they do that because
Sergey city's been out for like ten
years
well circus city was bought they bought
everything cute so all those guys like
Andrew Smith is just sitting around
could be wrong but I think Tiger Direct
which was a huge already up ecommerce
place bot Circuit City hmm I said they
must have I don't know what they bought
per se cuz they're already selling
electronics so they were like behind the
scenes like IBM or something like
it was big news though I'm actually
gonna be partnering with IBM okay
I'm sure anything is better than the
purchase timber like made with [ __ ]
Facebook's in Berlin you mean MySpace
it wasn't myspace it was a face but all
I say what the [ __ ] are you talking
about Justin Timberlake bought Facebook
what a loser my face my face not a music
thing yeah he wanted to bring myspace
back as well oh yeah my myspace music
right people's on having those players
on anything yeah he wanted to make it a
huge platform for emerging artists like
kind of like how bad campus but a way
better platform but it was myspace and
nobody gave a [ __ ] that's like I want to
buy Saturn I'm gonna bring Saturn back
the car I don't what happened to that
car I just sucked no offense if you
owned it no no I remember I remember it
like in high school
people had Saturn's and they'll get it
brand new and I'm like that's dope you
have a brand new car that I think I'd
rather have a 95 for Saturn they went
through I remember right before they
closed down they went through a huge
design revamp and it was way better than
their old [ __ ] but it still didn't save
them yeah that one else yeah they came
back at a very bad time because I think
like soon after that they had that whole
the whole economy went to [ __ ] right and
then they were doing cash for clunkers
at that point so they just they just did
it in a very bad time Saturn's were
always like that you know junior high
teacher car or like the lunch lady car
it's like it's like middle-aged lady car
and they're always burgundy yeah so back
to Circuit City though they're saying
that once they revamp their website
they're gonna have advanced in reality
video chat with tech support and they're
gonna be partnering up with IBM Watson's
artificial intelligence platform like
customers can have a personal shopper
sort of for their tech but they're liars
though right because they're now real
people how are they lying well they're
just lying they're not real people I
don't like that
[Music]
yes yeah they're coming back yeah after
they filed for bankruptcy and all that
stuff you know who I want to see come
back different restaurants from my
childhood my razón it was like this huge
indoor playground type of thing it was
the next level Chuckie Cheese yeah
exactly easy discovery yeah I would see
those commercials I never been into
saying something like that
yeah well they had a tuner yes they did
I like that but I also missed the old
sizzler like what the hell happened you
the old scissor was nasty or maybe I was
a child it I did we think everything's
bombed though I thought Hometown Buffet
was like three Michelin star yeah just
just to put it in perspective remember
when we went to that one time restaurant
with with the pop bar crew yeah that
Bart said he used to go to this [ __ ]
bastard yo this is Bob even this will
took a spoonful he's like Hamburger
Helper and like something right some
garbage hey change the recipe on me dude
let it change the recipe book no I feel
like they did cuz you know the
strawberry shortcake the the this ice
cream bar yeah - it tastes different
yeah it totally tasted it's not as sweet
disease it's because they took out the
wack chemicals that's why just like the
Lucas so they don't sell anymore they
need to make things cheap again you know
what's amazing about Lucas you could buy
it and then throw it away in a drawer
for like seven years and take it out -
it's just the same yeah it's good
apocalypse food I have it in my drawers
in like my Cerritos house just randomly
I'll open it I'll see it Oh awesome
they don't sew anymore they just they
have like different versions of it or I
don't know they've made it smaller and
like waste meters
our how are people gonna get their daily
let requirement I know right
chew their pencils oh they don't use
pencils anymore all right for our next
story that was this car that crashed
into the second story of a building I
saw that picture what the [ __ ] what yeah
thing what the hell is this whole deal
you know what I realized too about [ __ ]
like this is that I'm so desensitized to
views now I saw the picture I was like
whoa all right and I just moved back I
didn't read about it and you look me too
I saw it all over Instagram it looks
like art doesn't it yeah it looks like
amazing mortgage a movie set or
something it is are the lighting droning
there did anyone die no okay good you
know like all fast and furious you go on
the [ __ ] trucks that carry the cars
they use that as a rap and then they
jumped in the car like that sorta would
happen about in so Vin Diesel is driving
that [ __ ]
so this happen in Santa Ana knocking on
CCTV so I'm gonna show you guys what
happens the car just missing another car
right whoa whoa cuz it's kind of like
wow how did that happen Oh leave whoa
yo a car recorded that with the bus oh
my god
new cameras are dull everyone everybody
should be recording everyone got an
angle it looked like a movie it didn't
like a stud usually all the dirt that it
picked up damn what happened so this
happens world wasn't expecting it I
didn't think a tire was gonna squish me
they destroyed my house luckily no one
was in the building itself there were
two passengers in the car
this happened around like 5:30 in the
morning
and the driver admitted that he was
under the influence of drugs when this
happened what kind of drugs I would have
never thought this you know they didn't
mention probably meth 5:30
that's a meth time drug some drug that
made him think that he could fly over
that building I don't know what that
[ __ ] is he goes if I hit this rap watch
yeah the car was stuck in that building
for a whole hour once the medical
response got there had been a whole
another hour after that like the car was
still there but was he just sitting in
the car the whole time or did he like
open the door I don't know that much
that's a strong [ __ ] building that's
a great building I thought the car would
be like yeah well when YCJA Lee they
rescued the driver they got the driver
out and then they noticed that something
else is moving in the car they're like
what the hell and then they realized
that there was a passenger in there and
they kept trying to tell the passengers
like don't move don't do any of the
weight distractions in the car could
just fall out of the building so luckily
they were able to take out the passenger
everyone was fine
yeah it's crazy was it a vacant building
after our you know 5:13 week so they had
to find out that there was a passenger
in the car not because the guy pulled
him was because they figure out
themselves I know some say it's probable
on this thing I know is there somebody
else with you absolutely not he's
denying everything
nope there's nobody else are there was a
fire that broke out but then luckily
they were able to extinguish it quickly
I want to do that without consequences
like jumbo Clark yeah to feel
weightlessness and then just to cry like
this is so scary
you can feel weightlessness it's that
[ __ ] Bart throw you uh but in a car I
don't know if you'll feel like the
elevator feeling I think you'll feel
like the launch feeling like a like a
airplane or something
mm but then you feel the impact because
your car goes inside some drywall [ __ ]
you know it's pretty cool I've been
watching this this Indian I think Indian
or Punjabi series on Netflix right now
absolutely terrible one of the worst
things I've ever seen in my life but
it's so bad it makes me laugh into tears
wait is it the one where it's like the
farm is being sold or like there's the
lab no this is one where this
with her name is Gandhi and so gati she
has superpowers to save the whole world
from demons and so there's just one
scene where they're in the car and by
the way like Punjabi slash Indian films
are [ __ ] hilarious because they put
in 14 different cuts for no reason this
is one car chasing that lasts about 15
minutes and they put in literally I
counted 12 eight there was one angle
from beneath the car from the side
another wide one from the and they're
going hella slow by the way but they're
trying like it's and so she goes her
master talks to her from the distance
from them from with his mind right he's
telling you where to go and they were
jumping off a cliff and so they jump off
the cliff that which is by the way pop
it like 800 feet and something out the
car magically just lands and they just
walk up okay what next and so but that
fall was so funny because the fall
lasted a good 20 seconds so they're just
doing this if you guys go on Netflix you
should watch it it's the funniest thing
I've seen on what is it called I don't
know I'll look it up for you no but they
have they have some movies like that cuz
I recently watch one and it was yeah
yeah you just like there's another one
called I think it's called eh bad bah
bah eighty so another one it's about
this dude that could take your pain and
put it to yourself but it's supposed to
be a comedy sitcom but they just had
this one random soundboard that for no
reason so he'll just be talking right so
so what are you going to do later to so
it's pretty cool for our last story
there was this wannabe rapper that one
did it gets Rick Ross's attention cuz
you know it you guys didn't know Rick
Ross owns many Wingstop locations Oh
wannabe rapper he lost a lot of weight
through this so funny I like Wingstop
yeah he owns thirty thirty of them the
garlic parmesan wing oh yeah yeah so
then this wannabe rapper he decided to
get Rick Ross's attention by robbing one
of his locations what I wish
was crazy yeah he did it with a friend
craziest [ __ ] I've ever seen in my
life
what the hell is that sweetly didn't
want them to see this person at all yeah
this is the employee that's like a dump
cars just blur the figure they just took
up a whole scene they turned them into
[ __ ] minecraft dirt all right here we
go
initially they he got away but then they
were able to capture him because of this
CCTV footage yeah it's crystal clear on
his pace mm-hmm you even zoom into yeah
that was it
that's so funny I know what happened
where was this sack we rented this video
just put in a mosaic blur but they
didn't track the object so it just stays
there wha where was this location this
took place in Memphis Memphis Tennessee
so this 23 year old named Cedric do you
look right diced pineapples oh go ahead
you know you use the one that held up
the place
simple bugger on his upper lip that's a
long booger that is a bad date I believe
oh there's a documentary on Netflix
about the real Rick Ross and then ol
Freeway Ricky yeah he's trying to get
Rick Ross to like stop using that name
cuz he used it he's like you knows my
name dude what the [ __ ] oh there's a
real one there's a real one and then
there's a rapper persona the rapper one
took the original ones like name and
infamy and then but then though the the
rapper one he's like a card like a he
was a corrections officer hey you never
really did any that stuff he did but he
took the persona of Rick Ross and then
he that's how he got famous with the
name and so wannabe rapper wants to be
follow another one like wannabes on
wannabes pretty much that's cool yeah so
ridiculous it's like really you're gonna
get this was attention by holding up
when I was busy like if I rob the
Wingstop
I get caught so fat lesbian food in
there I just wouldn't leave do I love
their garlic parmesan [ __ ] and their
lemon pepper one person that burns bomb
dude that's just so [ __ ] good man I
don't understand why wigs are so many to
so much calories fry it don't they yeah
they fry it oh what the [ __ ] man don't
like this Broadway last
but it's the oil and the batter cuz all
the skin still on there and no throw
that's what all the fat is because I
want you to tell them to cheese but
sometimes B there's these fairies that
sprinkle this fat does okay you know
when they pre batter like I had a
laundress
they put a bit of batter a bit a bit of
batter and then they [ __ ] fry it or
whatever oh I like that better than the
just baked ones cuz the baked ones soft
old crotch are you able to fry chicken
with no skin or you have to have a thick
skin well if you find with us getting
this just it's just gonna be greasy as
[ __ ] I mean you can but that's how they
do the chicken strips
yeah but they put a battery dude the
batter yes oh you mean like frying
without anything just put like fry the
muscle can we we should cancel lunch and
just go get some wings today it's a poor
Rick Ross I [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
I could eat wings all day what's the
most of eating wings like 25 25 is round
you sound so disappointed because I
thought I could hey I wish I could be 40
I feel like you can eat I don't know I
never can never guess we got it but you
know I'd probably do like we probably do
it but don't remember the number yeah I
know they feel like we ordered a [ __ ]
ton out of laundress one time and we're
like we could do a hundred no problem
and then we're like now we can yeah I
think the most I've ever it was like in
the mid 20s because I thought I could
eat like 40 because they're so tiny and
so cute you're really good with your
mouth cuz I cuz you're the one that
taught us all how to take it off like
you ha ha
and then it comes out with just bone yes
that's what I mean it's pretty awesome
[Music]